[Musique]
et on commence avec cette information
Jean-Noël Barot et Aurélien Rousseau
étai au centre hospitalier de Versailles
aujourd'hui le ministre de la santé et
le ministre délégué chargé de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications étit présent un an
après la cyberattaque le but féliciter
les équipes et présenter le plan
d'investissement pour sécuriser les
données patients et l'activité médicale
direction manie Lamo une famille à dû
quitter son domicile après avoir subi
des menaces de mort dans la nuit du 8
décembre dernier pierrelouis Brière a
reçu C appel anonyme le menaçant de mort
l'homme de 30 ans membre du comité
citoyen de maniléamo est accusé
d'islamophobie après avoir posé des
questions à propos d'un projet de
mosquée une plainte a été déposée pour
menace de mort et alors est-ce que le
maire s'est emparé de l'affaire le maire
de la ville Bertrand Ouillon appelle à
la raison et à l'apaisement dans un
communiqué publié le 8 décembre dernier
à l'attention de tous les manicoises
toutes les manicoises et manicois vivre
action du côté des républicains Hutman
nasrou président de la Fédération LR des
ivelines interrogé par le JDD condamne
les faits tout comme Jean-Michel fogous
président de l'agglomération de 50 ans
liveline également sondé par le JDD de
son côté Valérie pcres demande sur X
ancien Twitter que la famille soit
protégée et que les auteurs soient mis
hors d'état de nuire et du côté du
chénéo qu'cour c'est un lycéen qui a été
arrêté après avoir menacé de mort son
professeur de mathématiques ça s'est
passé à l'établissement scolaire privé à
catholique Blanche de Castille l'élève
âgé de 16 ans a proféré des menaces de
mort via une publication Instagram dans
laquelle figurait la photo du professeur
une enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
de Versailles l'adolescent a interpellé
le 17 décembre dernier à son domicile et
pour le moment toujours en garde à vue
attention si vous prenez la 14 à partir
d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'à jeudi prochain
l'autoroute est fermée de 22h à 5h du
matin Michel le groupe SANEF programmeré
cette fermeture dans le cadre du projet
de transformation de l'axe
Paris-Normandie en flux libre démarré en
mai 2023 le projet se poursuit avec la
pose de portique sur la 14 et plus
précisément sur la barrière de phage de
Montesson et sur les deux sites du
diffuseur numéro 6a de chamboursi ils
permettront à terme l'identification et
la détection des véhicules dès juin
prochain laa 14 sera donc la première
portion de l'axe Paris Normandie à
passer en péage en flux libre dorénavant
à carrière souspoissie les animaux au
aussi leur cimetière c'est une première
dans les iines un colombarium animalier
a été inauguré samedi 16 décembre dans
le parc de l'Hôtel de Ville cet espace
dédié éclos de 500 m car peut accueillir
72 urnes d'animaux de compagnie les
tarifs varient selon la durée de la
concession compter entre 150 et 450 €
pour les carrièrrois et le double pour
les nonrésidents un anniversaire à
présent ce weekend c'était les 30 ans du
lycée de Villeroi à guancour pour
célébrer cet anniv anniversaire
l'établissement accueillé samedi 16
décembre d'anciens élèves et professeurs
au programme concert flashmob et
rencontre l'occasion unique de faire un
bon dans le temps écoutez l'esprit a pas
changé parce que Villarois c'est c'est
un esprit de bonheur de vivre et l'école
elle a besoin de ça aussi j'ai vu des
élèves que j'ai quitté en 2017 sont déjà
maman là ça fait un peu un choc ça pas
changé non c'est toujours les mêmes
couleurs les mêmes coloris les mêmes
emplacements aussi fondamentalement il
n'a pas changé et ça fait bizarre de de
naviguer de revenir dans les couloirs
les escaliers c'est vrai que c'est ça
apporte un moment de nostalgie ça fait
plaisir ça fait plaisir de revenir de
voir bah que d'autres ont pris notre
place ça fait plaisir aussi de donner
des nouvelles de ce qu'on est devenu et
cetera près de 400 personnes étaient
présentes toute la journée le lycée de
Villarois a été inauguré en
1993 chaque année 800 élèves sont
accueillis pour intégrer l'une des
quatre filières proposées et on termine
avec la actualité du moment Michell Noël
pour la 2e édition de son marché trappe
à vugand une dizaine de chalets se sont
installer ce weekend pour une semaine
place de la meurise vous pourrez y
retrouver des produits artisanaux des
décorations des confiseries mais aussi
un stand de jouet à prix symbolique
est-ce qu'il va y avoir des animations
aussi une patinoire a été installée à la
Halle culturelle de la merurise elle
sera ouverte à partir du 20 décembre
jusqu'au 5 janvier mais pendant les 2
semaines de vacances d'autres activités
seront proposer à la Merise atelier
créatif avec les centres sociaux
culturels réalité virtuelle avec la
cyberbase ou encore atelier ludique avec
la maison des jeux il y en aura pour
tous les goûts Mathilde et bien merci
beaucoup Michel midoro pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une information ou une
image qui vous a marqué près de chez
vous n'hésitez pas à nous la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news